c'est toute une vie qui se déroule
devant vos yeux la vie de création de
françoise sullivan le musée d'art
contemporain le constat qu'en ce moment
une rétrospective qui va d'ailleurs
sillonner le canada jusqu'en 2021
depuis des décennies la peintre
sculpteur danseuse chorégraphe françoise
sullivan accompagne les grands
changements dans l'histoire de l'art du
québec à commencer par ce coup d'éclat
il y à 70 ans
le manifeste du refus global un appel
d'air pour la création pour la liberté
j'ai rencontré françoise sullivan en fin
d'après midi
ramses rival bonsoir bienvenue à 24,60
bonsoir quelques jours les capitaux ne
peut pas héberger le plaisir que ça nous
fait juste parce qu'on peut le dire
d'entrée de jeu 95 ans c'est votre âge
70 ans depuis la signature du refus
global une formidable rétrospective au
musée d'art contemporain une exposition
qui va voyager à travers le canada qui
est passé par le lieu mythique de
baie-saint-paul vos oeuvres voyage non
seulement dans le temps et dans l'espace
comment accueillez-vous cette
anniversaire ou cette nouvelle
reconnaissance pour l'anniversaire
je trouve que c'est bien d'en parler je
crée bien que de le célébrer soixante
dix ans quand même pour ce qui est un
fait et je pense que c'est peut-être un
peu pour ça comme invité pour cette
dernière exposition au musée d'art
contemporain qui qui va changer de lieu
à fermer temporairement parce qu'ils ont
pas créé tout un autre musée d'art
contemporain beaucoup plus grand du
spacieux alors cette passion qui vous
anime et en 1948 en signant avec seize
autres personnes également paul émile
borduas ce refus se manifeste du refus
global cet esprit là cet esprit rebelle
de contrat vous habite toujours 70 ans
plus tard oui certainement d'une autre
taxe
mais continue oui on a des causes on a
toujours des causes pour lesquelles
shabbat way est là et là quelle cause
vous inspire le plus ce matin mais
d'abord c'est l'environnement
on peut pas passer par lui si oui est ce
que vous craignez que la planète ne
meurt par notre propre mais si on n'y
fait pas attention il faut il faut être
vigilant
est-ce que vous avez essayé se manifeste
je pense ça serait une bonne idée d'en
lire juste une phrase pour ce qu il ne
leur est pas lui depuis longtemps c'est
quand même costaud comme texte mais
s'est dit en rompre définitivement avec
toutes les habitudes de la société se
désolidariser de son esprit utilitaire
refus d'être sciemment au dessus de nos
possibilités psyché refus de fermer les
yeux sur les vices les duperies
perpétrés sous le couvert du savoir du
service rendu de reconnaissance du cette
quête ligne se convainc page
alors vous pourriez leur signer
aujourd'hui je suis absolument et puis
quand on pense place à la magie place à
l'amour
elle a sollicité
on n'a pas besoin d'en dire plus fêtez
bigand et là vous pourriez signé il ya
des textes qui circulent le pacte pour
l'environnement vous pourriez signer
toutes ces points ces pétitions pour
l'humain alors cette rétrospective mère
lumière votre oeuvre
ça commence en 1948 et vous n'êtes pas
que pas un transat sculpteur êtes
chorégraphe vous avez dansé
c'est important pour vous de conjuguer
toutes ses formes d'art oui je pense que
toute la vie semble avoir eu des
périodes de très différentes mais la
force qui menaient tout ça c'est
toujours la même je sais que j'ai
toujours voulu travailler dans les arts
dette
une astuce vous avez dix ans pensant
qu'à vous
déjà commencé à -6 mais oui alors cessé
d'avoir réaliser vos rêves d'enfants que
les oui sauf que montréal c'est un
endroit où bien sembler être aussi
grands que ceux qui venaient d'europe ou
d'ailleurs
et si tu es patafil d'accéder de créer
d'accéder à la liberté dans le fond si
c'était vous avez besoin de liberté
avait la chape de plomb de l'église est
présent dans le refus global
c'était présent et on peut dire que leur
fils d'obala pays une période de sept
ans avant de préparation et nous étions
tous passionnés et qui était émis dans
le dans le texte c'est est ce qu'on
croyait quoi vous croyez encore dans
cette exposition il ya des oeuvres
choisies et j'imagine ont un lien il ya
des hommes ont dit que l'oeuvre à marja
pietersen c'est une de vos oeuvres les
plus inspirés est ce que c'est vrai
c'est possible du tout ce qu'elle
représente pour vous cette qu'on voit
c'est un hommage à quelqu'un qui a été
très proche de moi l'homme de votre vie
oui le père de vos enfants et est qui
qui devenu
très grande artiste aussi ses cinq sens
absolument magnifique
en beaucoup de de la terre du soleil des
étoiles du ciel de la pluie
douch a été fait par lui d'une passion
sport bild
alors c'est en hommage à ceux qui ont
participé et il ya des oeuvres aussi
récente que les damiers et terre rouge
est ce qu'il ya un fil conducteur entre
toutes ces heures mais il ya un fil
conducteur un truc tout ce que j'ai fait
oui alors en voyant en rétrospective ce
que je musée maffre en ce moment c'est
une rétrospective c'est ma vie qui
défile
oui ça rend sa très émouvant et est ce
que vous vous reconnaissez bien dans sa
wii wii et que nous si on voit là
l'exposition d'oeuvres en oeuvre
qu'est-ce qu'on devrait en retenir deux
vous donc sensible oui parce que c'est
des postes qui vous touche
oui que ce soit la peinture ou de la
sculpture ou ou la danse ou même la
chorégraphie c'est ce que j'ai fait
c'est un flic que la vie fut défilé pour
moi ça passe vite ah oui mais ça
continue de baisser sur élèves et vous
vous paye d'ailleurs les tableaux de
2018 sont inspirés de la même passion il
ya les dames il y à terre rouge qu'est
ce qui vous a motivé dans ces deux
tableaux j'ai commencé avec ça et
puisque j'ai continué et pendant le
parcours
toutes les petites
décision qui pour prendre
continuellement continuellement quel
moment de créer vos de décevoir de
décision une décision
oui à chaque moment à chaque chaque
instance pourrait dire parce qu'on vous
commencez une oeuvre ne savait pas
encore comment elle va se terminer on
s'imagine non le grand défi de la
création
oui oui et aujourd'hui vous peignez
encore m'avait dit juste avant
l'entrevue vous venez de recevoir une
toile une grande toile de huit pieds par
six pieds oui alors c'est tout un projet
ce qu elle l est déjà en vous cette
oeuvre leur gilles daigneault de la
fondation molinari peut faire une
exposition sur les hommages que j'ai
rendu déjà d'autres artistes et il m'a
demandé de faire un hommage à fernand
leduc et je me prépare
intérieurement en pensant à son oeuvre à
ce qu'ils étaient comme artiste et
j'espère lui rendre honneur et vous
pourrez nous présenter cette oeuvre là
c'est assez rapidement huige
oui l'exposition prévue pour le 28
février
mais entre temps j'ai une exposition à
toronto où je devrais aller et il ya
différentes activités
que j'aurais à faire alors je vais
devoir travailler régulièrement windows
sur un échafaudage la wiimote et dans un
autre match ici c'est quand même un
grand défi en rétrospective soixante dix
ans ça peut être long mais ça c'est
aussi créer surtout quand vous regardez
l'évolution de l'art de l'art visuel de
l'art tout court au québec depuis toutes
ces années
etes-vous sereine heureuse de la place
de l'art dans nos vies dans notre
société au québec
je trouve qu'elle n'est pas si grand la
place dindar mais pour moi on pourrait
faire une plus grande place
oui comment avez vous reçu au fil des
années tous ces hommes asiana que j'ai
retenu est intéressante elle vous avez
dans votre catalogue de l'exposition
il y a le télégramme du ministre georges
émile lapalme les affaires culturelles
le premier ministre des affaires
culturelles et c'est très très amusant
parce que
c'est canadienne pacific avec amitié qui
vous annonce que vous avez le premier
prix section sculpture cordiales
félicitations georges émile lapalme
madame françoise sullivan c'était pour
lui une sculpture c'était un concours
oui et c'était en 1968 3way deux
sculptures en terre depuis peu mais je
fais j'ai grave depuis toujours à
l'école des beaux-arts oui mais ça a été
mais je recevais un montant de 3000 $ et
pour l'époque c'était nouveau et c'est
ce qui m'a permis d'avoir un gardien
certains moments pour pas cher eric et
qu'ils en vain ça m'a aidé beaucoup mais
j'ai lu être mais dollars pour l'époque
stand fortune est ce qu'il ya dans les
enfants petits enfants
une relève des gens qui s'en suit vos
traces précisément mais elle l'accueille
l'amour de l'art c'est plus grand amour
de votre villa après monsieur petrus et
les enfants et les enfants replace les
choses en perspective oui si vous aviez
à souhait pour l'avenir quel serait-il
pour moi c'est de continuer on vous le
souhaite
très généreusement très chaleureusement
on veut voir de nouvelles oeuvres de
françoise van merci beaucoup madame sol
viennent d'être passés en studio en
cette fin d'année 2010 8 c'est une façon
de marquer votre histoire l'histoire de
vos co signataire du refus global et sa
contribution à l'évolution du québec et
à son expression à travers là je
remercie merci beaucoup